there is a warning this afternoon about  fake vaccine vials making their way here  to southern nevada  fake covid 19 protections as it turns  out have become big business  our i-team found homeland security and  ice have seized millions of dollars  worth of counterfeit items  these pictures here show non-medical  grade masks and gloves  fake remedies to cure covet even at-home  test kits  and it's all fraudulent next federal  agencies  expect scammers to try and sell fake  vaccines  whether it's an individual who's trying  to make a fast buck or  a business who is trying to  take advantage of opportunities in  foreign countries  in order to bring in products that  aren't approved  federal agents say you have to go to a  licensed medical professional  to get that vaccine